En me baladant sur facebook je suis tombé sur cette vidéo
Qu'est ce qui s'est passé est ce que ce sont vraiment les ondes 5G qui ont fait ça et si oui par quel mécanisme
La 5G chez c'est le successeur de la 4G LA nouvelle technologie en train d'être déployée dans toute la france
Avec ça l'internet sur ton téléphone pourrait être 20 fois plus rapide, une vidéo youtube 4K chargée en moins d'un quart de seconde
Sauf que pour beaucoup cette invention serait dangereuse: tumeurs, dégâts au cerveau, destruction de la nature
Quand est il vraiment ? Qui du gouvernement, des opérateurs mobiles ou des mouvements citoyens se trompent ?
Les ondes sont elles un danger ? Pour comprendre les polémiques on va revenir à la base: qu'est ce qu'une onde électromagnétique ?
Ce mot fait peur mais, est ce que tu savais que même au fin fond de la campagne
tu es constamment baigné dans des ondes car tout ce que tu vois la lumière, les couleurs ce sont des ondes électromagnétiques,
des ondes qui se situent au centre de ce grand spectre électromagnétique
tout à gauche vous avez les infrarouges
à droite les ultraviolets ça ce sont les rayonnements que vous ne voyez pas
sauf si par exemple tu as un casque infrarouge militaire
ça permet de voir cette lumière invisible cette chaleur qui est en fait une lumière
Qui émane actuellement de ton corps, si on voit plus loin dans le spectre sur le rayonnement infrarouge
on trouve des trucs rigolos comme
les ondes de ton micro ondes ou le wifi oui oui ton wifi c'est un peu comme de la lumière ton wifi émet des photons
ton ordinateur les voit mais pas toi. La différence entre ces différents types d'onde ça va être
leur longueur d'onde, la lumière visible à une longueur d'onde à l'échelle d'une bactérie, une radio c'est de l'ordre du mètre voire du
kilomètre ça veut dire qu'une longueur d'onde peut littéralement faire ta taille voire beaucoup plus. Là où ça devient dangereux
c'est quand les ondes ont de très petites longueurs d'onde, pour ça faut remonter dans le spectre et s'intéresser aux ultraviolets rayons x et au delà
C'est pour ça qu'on te dit que de mettre de la crème solaire
C'est pour ça que quand tu passes une radio le médecin se protège, la réalité c'est que dans ces conditions
tu te fais bombarder pars des longueurs d'ondes nanometriques, des ondes dites ionisantes.
Elles sont tellement énergétique qu'elles peuvent perturber les électrons dans tes atomes, ça va produire des effets en chaîne
qui amène à la destruction des cellules et
potentiellement des cancers. Ok, maintenant que je vous ai fait peur, où se trouvent les ondes 5G là dedans? Alors non, je vous rassure
elles ne sont pas ionisants. Associer la 5G à des radiations nucléaires
c'est très malhonnête. Au contraire la 5G à des longueurs d'onde plutôt grandes
jusqu'à 1 cm. Pour info les ondes wifi c'est autour de 10 cm, ouais mais vous allez me dire "ton histoire de taille là
ça compte pas trop, un four à micro-ondes c'est aussi des grosses longueurs d'onde et pourtant tu y mets la main
ça crame" Oui et cet exemple est plutôt intéressant car sache-le
Les ondes de ton wifi et les ondes qui chauffent des aliments sont de la même longueur d'onde
alors pourquoi mon wifi ne fait pas chauffer mon thé. Parce qu'il y a deux autres paramètres: le focus et la puissance
Un micro-ondes concentre l'onde dans un petit volume
Là où le wifi envoie ses ondes un peu partout. Un micro-ondes opère à mille watt là où le wifi est à 0,1 watt
dix mille fois moins quoi et c'est ça qui pose problème avec la 5G, l'onde est certes
inoffensive mais, là où la 4G envoie des ondes un peu partout comme ton wifi, la 5G va les concentrer dans des espaces de tirs
très précis à très haute puissance c'est ce qu'on appelle un réseau phasé et ça ça fait flipper mais c'est des tirs de quelques watts
à peine plus que la 4G
Vous n'allez pas cuire sur place il faudrait un tir 100 fois plus puissant pour que cela commence à peine à vous picoter. En réalité,
la 5G permettra
paradoxalement d'émettre moins d'ondes, au lieu d'arroser tout à pleine puissance les ondes sont répartis beaucoup plus intelligemment tout aussi paradoxalement si certains vivaient
dans la peur d'être entouré d'onde, la 5G passera à peine les murs de votre maison. Ce sont des ondes d'assez courte portée,
elle vous pénètreront beaucoup moins facilement que la WiFi ou la 4G. Si la 5G avait existé avant le wifi, ses avantages
aurait sûrement été utilisé pour prouver que la 5G c'est le bien et le wifi le mal. On ne prend que ce qui nous arrange
Mais alors pourquoi les arbres sont cramés ?
On va revenir sur cette vidéo facebook avec l'arbre. Les habitants de cette ville britannique très inquiets ont
naturellement demandé à la désinstallation de l'antenne, la mairie refuse
et gagne son procès: les ondes sont mises hors de cause car il y a plein d'autres raisons qui peuvent
expliquer ce qui s'est passé avec l'arbre le fait déjà que ça peut être
naturel c'est assez commun de voir ça sur les arbres, possibilité que la personne ait appliqué des produits chimiques elle même
Le doute est permis puisque de toute évidence
le sol de l'arbre est traitée chimiquement
car oui la cause peut être humaine
C'est un peu comme ces expériences qui montrent que les graines ne germent plus en présence de wifi, on pose à côté des graines un
gros portable bien brûlant avec un ventilo qui assèche bien l'air et on dit que c'est le wifi qui en est la cause. Oui bah là non
les causes c'est la chaleur et le ventilo. On a fait de vrais tests scientifiques
avec les plantes et ni la wifi et ni la 5g n'ont montré d'effet négatif
notable et
répétable, pourtant des photos comme ça il y en a plein
et à chaque fois ça peut s'expliquer par exemple ici: c'est un effet de perspective
Il y a l'arbre et il y a l'antenne derrière car oui on essaye de faire des antennes qui ressemblent à des arbres pour mieux les intégrer au paysage
Bon ok ça c'est un vrai argument contre la 5G c'est moche
mais s'il n'y a pas d'effet sur les plantes peut-il y en avoir sur les animaux ?
Il y avait cette histoire de mort de centaines d'oiseaux aux pays-bas en 2018 mais là encore, c'était de la désinformation
L'article était complètement piper la cause était tout autre
mais, oui de fortes ondes peuvent légèrement désorienter les oiseaux et les abeilles, leur sens étant basé sur un compas magnétique naturel.
Mais non ça ne les tue pas
En même temps le mec des oiseaux avait lancé la rumeur qui a affirmé que les incendies en californie
était une punition de l'élite pour imposer la 5G. Avec internet c'est très facile de prendre quelque chose d'anecdotique
et de se tromper sur les causes et les effets. Si demain tu meurs en mangeant de la ratatouille
Il suffirait de prendre une photo de toi avec ton plat et les réseaux feraient la suite
Le pire c'est au royaume-uni et aux États-Unis, actuellement il y a une théorie du complot qui voudrait que la 5G soient liés à la pandémie actuelle
, genre la 5G renforce le virus, ou qu'il a été diffusée volontairement par le gouvernement profitant ainsi du confinement pour installer les antennes
Ah non mais quand les journaux sont obligés de tirer ça tu te dis quand même que la psychose va beaucoup trop loin
l'O.M.S à pu conclure sur la 5G:
Ils disent: "les connaissances scientifiques sont désormais plus complète que celle que l'on possédait sur la plupart des produits chimiques"
Ceci dit certains n'y crois toujours pas l'O.M.S serait dans le complot. Dans le complot seulement quand ça les arrange parce qu'effectivement
l'O.MS classe la 5G comme possiblement
cancérigène et c'est un argument souvent utilisé sauf que c'est cancérigène dans la même catégorie que l'aloe vera ou les légumes en saumure
En fait cette catégorie regroupe tous les agents dont on ne peut pas être sûr à 100%
et puisqu'on ne peut pas être sûr de grand chose...
Bref, faites attention aux études foireuse que vous voyez parfois passer. C'est un peu comme ces soi-disant études américaines
qui prouve que la bière rend
intelligent et que le sexe vous fait vieillir plus vite: c'est n'importe quoi et c'est généralement très vite debunké dites vous que la peur des
ondes est un gros business juteux, ça permet de vendre des brouilleurs d'ondes et d'autres objets pour vous en protéger
Mais, face à ses doutes pourquoi nous imposer la 5G ?
Et ça c'est une vraie question
Pourquoi il n'y a pas de démocratie quand il s'agit d'une nouvelle technologie ? Elles nous sont imposés sans qu'on ait notre mot à dire
et fatalement les citoyens, qui essaye de se défendre face à ça, consulte une information alternative
souvent d'assez mauvaise qualité et surtout mensongère. Sauf que la question de la 5G
c'est la même qui s'est posée au moment de l'arrivée du téléphone portable et de la wifi à l'époque certains étaient
terrifiés à l'idée d'avoir une box chez eux, il la mettait dans une pièce à part ou...
éteignait la box avant de dormir. Certains scientifiques parlaient de la WiFi comme d'une catastrophe sanitaire majeure
Une école en floride a failli même retirer ses installations sous la pression du public. Ma question est donc:
si vos parents avaient voté contre la wifi début des années 2000 auriez vous trouvez ça normal d'en être privé aujourd'hui !?
la 5G n'est pas une évidence. Actuellement mon internet marche bien sur mon téléphone, j'ai pas vraiment besoin de plus
sauf que la 4G est à bout de souffle avec l'arrivée des objets connectés, des voitures autonomes ou du streaming en haute qualité
Ils nous fallait une nouvelle technologie. Si vous avez déjà été un concert avec des milliers de téléphone allumés
Vous voyez bien que c'est impossible de capter quoi que ce soit. Imaginez ça dans dix ans, partout, tout le temps
la 5G c'est aussi la possibilité de ne pas avoir de latence, de pouvoir pratiquer la chirurgie à distance instantanément
sans avoir dix secondes de décalage comme quand tu regardes ton streaming favoris et enfin la 5G c'est plus écologique
Alors je sais que l'argument a l'air foireux comme ça la 5G va demander plus d'antennes puisque les ondes sont de courtes distances
plus antennes c'est donc plus d'exploitations de ressources naturelles
Mais, en même temps la 5G a un réseau plus intelligent plus ciblées y aura potentiellement moins de gâchis énergétique
Alors maintenant soyons honnêtes, si j'avais une antenne 5G à ma fenêtre
Bon même si je sais que c'est pas très dangereux, je serai pas non plus très content et pas très rassuré
Je sais aussi très bien que la 5G, actuellement, c'est une histoire de guerre commerciale et de gros sous avec des vrais enjeux de sécurité nationale
Vu que l'on fait tout en chine et qu'il y a la peur de l'espionnage
Tout ça ce sont de vrais arguments dans le débat et on doit pouvoir en discuter. La seule chose que je demande
c'est qu'on soit honnête
Le jour où on aura le petit 5G en haut de son portable, on sait que ce sera difficile de revenir en arrière
comme c'est difficile de repasser en 3G ou en EDGE.
Le monde change vite
Et c'est comme cette histoire de masques si on n'anticipe pas maintenant, si on fait pas les choses rapidement avant que la vague arrive
on va être beaucoup à râler
On commence à peine cette chaîne youtube avec la team est la même à tarte
donc si vous voulez nous soutenir avoir plus de vidéos
penser s'il vous plaît à vous abonner ça aide YouTube a nous remonter dans l'algorithme
Ça permet à ce genre de vidéos d'être vu par le plus de monde possible, ça nous motive aussi à continuer merci de m'avoir suivi
merci à tous les monteurs et la team de rédacteur allez les amis
CHAO
C'était Axel